Fine, fine.
Since everyone won’t stop asking, I’ve
decided to give you all what you want and
do a Horror History episode on Wyborn Lovat
from Coraline.
And the truth is, Wybie was only created for
the movie.
He’s not in the book at all, so he technically
has no history.
So remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, RING that deathbell--
No, I’ll obviously have to go off of the
movie and the movie alone for this episode,
but if you want to hear what goes on with
Wybie while he's off screen then stick around
to the end of this video.
[INTRO]
Part of what makes the world of Coraline special
is that the artistic choices made reflect
the themes of the story.
The book tells a tale of a girl who finds
this fake world and is intrigued by the small
differences it has to her world.
I like to think of the film as a whole, as
it’s own world to be treated differently
than the book, and the most noticeable difference,
the snowglobe of the film, if you will, is
the inclusion of Wybie.
Welcome to Horror History, my name is Why-Was-I-Born
and in today’s lesson we’ll be covering
the character who probably owns the most Jack
Skellington merch, Wyborn Lovat.
Of course, there is a much more practical
reason for Wybie’s inclusion, as explained
by director Henry Selick in an interview with
Cinemablend.
“[When I decided to add the character of
Wybie] I realized that Coraline needed someone
in her real world to talk to.
Another kid seemed the most simple way to
go.”
But the character that ended up on screen
was much more than a glorified exposition
prompter, so in order to understand Wybie’s
importance to the lore and history of this
dark, twisted world, let’s take it back
to the beginning of his story.
Wybie looks to be about Coraline’s age,
and lives with his Grandma in a property not
far from the Pink Palace Apartments where
Coraline lives.
It is not known what happened to his parents,
but we do know the fate of his Great Aunt.
She once lived with Wybie’s grandmother
in the Pink Palace before it was converted
into separate apartments.
As discussed in the Horror History episode
on The Other Mother, living at the Pink Palace
made her a target for the Beldam.
In the movie, the Beldam spies on her potential
victims through the eyes of this doll, which
is placed in the real world for the children
to find.
Wybie’s Great-Aunt became attached to the
doll, and one day she disappeared and became
trapped in the Beldam’s world.
I think Wybie’s Grandmother suspected some
foul play, because she moved out of the Palace
when she was old enough, and when it became
hers, she renovated it into apartments, and
didn’t allow families with children to move
there until the events of Coraline.
We don’t know why Coraline is an exception
of this rule, but there one line to suggest
that she simply had to rent the place to the
Joneses because of anti age discrimination
laws.
“Surprised she let you move in.
My Grandma, she owns The Pink Palace.
She won’t rent to people with kids.”
“What do you mean?”
“Well, I’m not supposed to talk about
it.”
On a side note, Wybie’s grandma is referred
to as ‘Grandma’ through most of the movie
and ‘Wybie’s Grandmother’ in the credits.
At one point, Coraline refers to her as Ms.
Lovat.
“Welcome Ms. Lovat.”
The woman doesn’t correct Coraline, so by
that logic, it was her son that was Wybie’s
father, passing down the last name Lovat all
the way to him.
The fact that she is Ms. Lovat rather than
Mrs. Lovat also suggests that she gave birth
to Wybie’s dad out of wedlock, meaning that
Wybie’s grandfather hasn’t been part of
the picture for some time now.
It’s also possible that Coraline just didn’t
know whether to call her Ms. or Mrs.
“I thought we got past that, but this guy
wants to bring it back.”
After the disappearance of her sister, she
locked the doll away in a chest, until it
was reclaimed by the Beldam and turned into
a Coraline doll, where it was then put back
in the chest for Wybie to find.
Other than exploring the area around his house
on his electric bicycle, Wybie seems to be
passionate about photography.
He makes friends with a wild cat, which he
sometimes feeds in exchange for the dead things
that cat brings him at night.
He first encounters Coraline after she moves
in when he hears he scream after the cat had
startled her.
He approaches and mistakes her for a water
witch, and rides in to take the stick that
he perceives to be her dowsing rod.
When they meet, we see that despite his intimidating
appearance, he’s actually pretty shy, oftentimes
stuttering and avoiding eye contact.
His hunched over posture does not exude confidence,
which coupled with the information that kids
are never usually moved into The Pink Palace,
we can conclude that he doesn’t have any
friends… other than The Cat that is.
Coraline has this same issue at the beginning
of the story.
She’s constantly bored and none of the adults
around her have time to play with her.
Despite this, Coraline and Wybie don’t really
get along when they first meet.
Wybie does tell her about the location of
the well though, before his Grandmother calls
him in, ringing a bell for him as she does
so.
“Wyborn?”
“Grandma...”
Wybie seems embarrassed by his Grandmother’s
strict control over his whereabouts.
I believe this may be because after all of
these years, she’s still scarred by losing
her sister, and fears the same could happen
to her grandson if he gets too close to The
Pink Palace.
As a result, Wybie has never been inside the
building.
“Grandma’d kill me.”
So he goes home and finds the doll, which
he recognizes to be identical to Coraline
and leaves it on her porch with a note.
The next morning he’s snooping around and
spies on her using some kind of Periscope
helmet.
When she catches him he claims to be hunting
banana slugs.
Director Henry Selick may have gone with banana
slugs as the creature of choice to setup what
happens to The Other Wybie later in the story.
Coraline claims to be annoyed by Wybie because
of his loud mouth, causing The Other Mother
to create a mute version of him in the other
world.
Banana slugs have a defense mechanism where
the mucus that they release contains chemicals
that are capable of numbing the tongue of
their predators.
Despite Coraline claiming to not like Wybie,
she does still seem to enjoy taking the photos
of him in various poses with the banana slug.
Outside of one other encounter with Coraline
where Wybie claims that Mr Bobinsky's jumping
mouse circus is a lie, the two would not encounter
each other until the next day, but Coraline does
meet his doppelganger, The Other Wybie.
As we established when I covered the history
of The Other Mother, the button-eyed doppelganger
forms of each character found in the other
world aren't really connected to their real-world
counterparts.
However, the duplicate versions can still
teach us about the nature of the originals,
because the Other Mother's intention was to
create more enticing forms of the people in
Coraline's life.
As with the Other Father the Other Wybie seems
to have a mind of his own, and only acts the
way he does out of fear for The Beldam.
In addition to being friendly and incapable
of speech, he's also less shy, stands up straight
and wears more conventional clothing.
He seems to be a more ideal version of Wybie
to be friends with Coraline, but like the
endless amounts of delicious food and freedom
offered by the Beldam's world, Other Wybie
ends up being another example of things being
better off as they were initially.
Coraline maybe doesn't realize how lonely
she is, and having a friend who doesn't talk
isn't doing her any favors in that regard.
One of the first things that Coraline asks
him, is if the treatment to make him silent
caused him any pain, and he immediately changes
the subject, probably knowing that he is under
constant scrutiny by The Other Mother.
The two go to see the jumping mouse circus,
the very same jumping mouse circus that the
real Wybie called BS on.
After seeing Coraline off to bed before she
exits from The Other World that night, The
Other Wybie shows that he really does have
good intentions by warning The Cat about the
true nature of the Other World.
Coraline returns to her world, and while Wybie
isn’t there the next day when Mr. and Mrs.
Jones take their daughter into town to buy
a uniform, there are other kids in that scene,
which tells us two things.
First, Coraline shows no interest in meeting
them despite her loneliness, because of their
erratic behaviour, which could be a clue that
the often awkward and reserved Wybie could
actually be a more compatible friendship for
her.
She may have gotten the wrong idea about him
from their initial meeting.
And second, there ARE other kids nearby, so
the fact that we never see Wybie play with
or talk about any other kids could mean that
he has no friends, and maybe I’m assuming
too much by saying this, but it’s easy to
imagine him being bullied for his outlandish
fashion choices and unconventional hobbies.
The Other Wybie, on the other hand, pun intended,
is copied from the original Wybie, but changed
in ways that The Beldam thought to be improvements.
Both versions seem to like Coraline and want
to help her.
In the case of the Other Wybie, The Beldam
may have made him friendly and likeable because
her goal was to try to make Coraline want
to stay.
She probably didn’t realize that Other Wybie’s
good intentions would be used against her.
I could see her thinking that making him mute
would stop him from helping Coraline in any
way, but that ends up not being the case.
The Other Wybie is forced to accompany her
to the theater… where he has a very weird
reaction to seeing the nearly naked Miss Forcible…
He keeps up the cheery attitude until he is
no longer needed.
As Coraline goes inside, The Other Mother
gives him a harsh reminder that he needs to
keep on a smile the whole time, despite the
fact that he’s clearly unhappy.
While Coraline is locked away in the mirror
realm, The Other Mother punishes Other Wybie
for his insubordination.
She uses her seamstress abilities to tie his
mouth into a permanent smile, ensuring that
he’ll never give Coraline any negative energy
towards Coraline.
It’s basically like when you go to a fast
food restaurant and the person at the counter
is smiling because they don’t want to get
fired, but deep down they probably are like,
“someone get me out of here.”
At this point, I think that Other Wybie has
been pushed to a breaking point.
He’s been brought into this world by the
Other Mother and forced to do her bidding.
He may not have had any hope for himself,
but thought that he could at least do the
brave thing and make sure Coraline doesn’t
share the same fate.
Ironically, he wears a chicken mask to cover
up his forced smile when he reaches into the
mirror realm to rescue her, and she removed
the cover up to find that The Other Wybie
was no chicken at all.
He manages to sneak her back to the gateway
between the two worlds, but when she tries
to invite him to come along, his hand erodes
into the stuffing used to make the doll that
was used to spy on each target.
I think this was his way of telling her that
he has no way to survive out there in the
real world.
He was just a tool created by The Beldam,
no different than the doll that Coraline had
discarded in the fire.
We never see The Other Wybie again after that,
but we can assume that he, no longer being
useful to The Other Mother, was discarded
as well.
The Other Mother hangs his clothes on the
flagpole atop her world as a warning to all
of her other creations about what will happen
if they disobey her.
Meanwhile, the original Wybie is still fine
and well, but he gets himself into a different
kind of trouble.
His Grandmother is upset with him for stealing
the doll that had once belonged to her sister.
Wybie tries to go back to Coraline’s flat
to ask for it, explaining that it wasn’t
his to give, and this causes Coraline to realize
that Ms. Lovat’s sister and the ghost girl
she had encountered are one and the same.
She brings Wybie inside, his first time setting
foot in The Pink Palace, and tries to explain
everything that she knew about the Other World,
which of course sounds crazy.
“Crazy!
AHHHHHHH--”
...and she gets upset and chases him out,
but when he returned home, he would find something
that changed his views on Coraline’s story.
His Grandmother showed him a picture from
her childhood.
The photograph shows Ms. Lovat and her sister,
who is holding the doll, which Wybie recognizes
from Coraline’s story.
He rushes out to try to find her and apologize
for not believing her, and finds her headed
back to the old well.
Before he gets the chance to say anything,
she is attacked by the rogue hand of The Beldam.
Using the same tongs he uses to catch the
banana slugs, he rides in and saves her, but
nearly throws himself into the well in doing
so.
Coraline saves him from falling in, but exposes
herself to an attack.
That is when Wybie puts an end to it by crushing
the hand with a rock, rescuing Coraline and
finally avenging the Great Aunt he never met
in doing so.
Together, they throw the hand down the well,
and as far as we know, The Beldam is never
heard from again.
Wybie apologizes for not believing Coraline
sooner, but she isn’t upset, and asks him
to bring his Grandma by the house so that
they can explain everything together.
I took this ending as, not only an ending
to The Beldam’s reign (with The Cat being
seen taking advantage of the freedom to now
travel between worlds as he pleases), but
also the ending of Ms. Lovat’s paranoia
about the curse of The Pink Palace and the
children who inhabit it.
She would finally be able to rest easy knowing
that her sister’s ghost was not in agony.
And finally, it marks the ending of loneliness
for both Coraline and Wybie, who now each
had a new friend their age.
Click the playlist on the left for my full
list of Horror History episodes including
those on the other characters of Coraline
and remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for
new horrors every week, RING the deathbeldam
for notifications and I will see you in the
next one.
Assuming, we both survive.